the storm could cause big problems for
new orleans if it doesn't make a direct
hit ida is bearing down on the big easy
and could make landfall 16 years to the
day
after hurricane katrina devastated the
gulf coast omar villafranca is in new
orleans where the time to evacuate is
running out good morning omar
that's right michelle good morning
governor john bel edwards says if you
plan to ride this storm out you better
be in that location by tonight but for
many here in new orleans i'd have formed
so fast they didn't have time to make a
plan to get out
cars stacked up bumper to bumper on
interstate 10 people looking to get out
ahead of ida's arrival new orleans mayor
latoya cantrell says she could not order
a mandatory evacuation for most of the
city because of how quickly the storm
developed
this is hurricane
louisiana those who stayed behind found
long lines of people scrambling for
generators fans and propane all we got
left for a few exchanges one two three
four to go
550 gallons in
four hours this morning
it didn't last many stores already
struggling to keep up with demand during
pandemic fueled supply shortages
shopping during covet is always hard but
it's a little bit harder now health
officials are concerned about covid
spreading in shelters less than half of
all louisiana residents are vaccinated
and cases hit an all-time high here less
than two weeks ago please make sure you
are making plans to stay healthy and
safe
and the way you do that is by
masking when you are not with people who
that you live that when you are with
people that you don't normally live with
in coastal saint bernard's parish the
race was on to get boats out of the
water nobody was out there shrimping
today and over there short season so
that ought to tell you and a lot when i
got in this morning late last night at
four o'clock about 75 80 percent of the
boats already left and for those staying
behind mayor cantrell had one final
message
shelter in place hunker down it is
vitally important
president biden has already signed a
federal emergency
declaration for the state of louisiana
fema is also already planning to send
about 150 medical personnel and dozens
of ambulances to the gulf coast just in
case they are needed because remember
the hospitals here are strained by covid
but dana at this point right now a
little bit of time to to plan and make
plans to get out and we gotta wait and
it's that early preparation that matters
the most omar thank you very much